an interesting random variable
associated with the Bernoulli process is
the time of the case success or the time
of the case arrival depending on what
kind of context we have in mind so the
picture is as follows the process starts
and we wait until the first arrival
occurs and the time that it occurs we
call that time y1 then we keep observing
the process and there is a time at which
a second arrival comes we call that time
y2 the process continues and there's a
certain time that the third arrival
comes we call that time y3 now the time
that the first arrival comes this is
also what we called t1 t1 is this length
it's the time until the first arrival
let us give a name to the time it takes
from the first to the second arrival and
we call that time t2 which is the second
inter arrival time and similarly we will
call t3 the time between the second and
the third arrival so we define in
general TK to be the difference between
two consecutive arrival times and of
course the time of the third arrival is
the sum of T 1 plus T 2 plus T 3 the
first three inter arrival times and more
generally YK is going to be the sum of
these K inter arrival times so in order
to study the random variable Y K and its
properties the way that we can proceed
is to understand first the random
variables T I what kind of random
variables are they well we know that t1
the time until the first arrival has a
geometric distribution with parameter P
now at the time of the first arrival
the process starts fresh so after this
time there will be a sequence of
independent Bernoulli
trials and t2 will be the number of
Bernoulli trials it takes until we see
an arrival so t2 will also be geometric
with the same parameter P furthermore
because the process starts fresh
whatever happens in the future after
this time is independent from whatever
happened in the past and so the random
variable T 2 will be independent from t1
and then by a similar argument t3 will
be independent from t1 and t2 and will
also have the same geometric
distribution based on these properties
we can now go ahead and calculate
properties of YJ YK is the sum of random
variables the expected value of YK is
the sum of the expected values of the
teens each one of the T's has a
geometric distribution with parameter P
and in particular has a mean of 1 over P
by adding those means we obtain that the
mean of Y K is K over P similarly the
variance of Y J will be equal to the sum
of the variances of the T is the reason
being that the TI's are independent and
so to find the variance of the sum it's
enough to just add the variances and we
have a formula for the variance of a
geometric and using that formula and
multiplying it by K we obtain the
variance of YK finally we would like to
calculate the PMF of Y K so we would
like to find this probability here the
probability that Y K takes on a specific
value equal to T notice that in this
argument were thinking of K as a fixed
given number for example we're
interested in the time of the fifth
arrival this is a random variable that
can take different values T and we want
to find the probabilities of those
different values T so think of K as
being fixed and T as a parameter that
varies and we want to carry out this
calculation for all possible choices of
T now what is this event here this is
the event that the cave arrival
occurs at time T so this means that at
time T we have an arrival but for this
to be the case arrival we must have K
minus 1 arrivals in the previous time
slots of which there's t minus 1 of them
the probability that YJ is equal to T is
the probability that these two events
happen K minus 1 arrivals in t minus 1
slots and 1 arrival at slot number T so
we are looking at the probability that
these two events occur now this event K
minus 1 arrivals in t minus 1 slots is
an event that completely determined by
whatever happens in the first t minus 1
time slots whereas the event of an
arrival at slot time T refers to
whatever happens during slot time T
because of our assumptions on the
Bernoulli process whatever happens
during these t minus 1 time slots is
independent from what happens in slot
number T so the probability of these two
events happening because of independence
will be the probability of the first
event happening k minus 1 arrivals at
time in time T minus 1 times the
probability of an arrival at time T
now the first probability is given by
the binomial formula in t minus 1 times
slots we want to have K minus 1 arrivals
and the binomial formula gives us an
exponent P to this power times 1 minus P
to the power that's the difference of
these two numbers which is T minus K and
then finally we multiply with the
probability of an arrival at time T
which is equal to P this P will cancel
the exponent of minus 1 up here and
leads us to this formula for the
probability that the K arrival happens
at time T naught is the range of the
random variable Y K the K arrival cannot
happen before time K you need at least K
time slots to obtain K arrivals so this
probability will be positive only
starting at time K and for future times
so this random variable Y K in general
will have a PMF of this form it's 0 for
T's smaller than K and then at time K in
general it's going to be a positive
entry and for future values of T it will
also have positive entries and this PMF
extends all the way to infinity because
it is possible that the K arrival takes
an arbitrarily long time to occur if we
consider different values of K of course
we will get a different PMF the PMF of Y
3 is different than the PMF of Y 2 and
the PMF of Y 3 will generally set to the
right of the PMF of Y 2 because the
third arrival generally will take longer
to occur than the second arrival